from the hill Pelosi predicts Democrats
will keep the house after November's
midterms she actually said it was going
to be a landslide she said come on yeah
she said uh we will hold the house by
winning more seats saying that Roe v
Wade is going to result in the Democrats
actually winning hey man I think it's an
important story to talk about because
we're about a month away and uh hubris
will be your downfall considering Elon
Musk making this move has them so
worried maybe that's actually a sign
they're not going to win a month out
early voting is beginning to start
mail-in voting votes are ballots are
going out Elon let's say Elon takes over
and let's say this time next week Donald
Trump is back on the platform is that
good or bad will that help Democrats or
hurt them in the midterms
what do you guys think I think Elon Musk
taking over Twitter will help the
Republicans in the midterms but if
Donald Trump comes back I think that
hurts the Republicans I think if Trump
comes back on Twitter it's going to hurt
him yeah because the only thing
Democrats have to campaign on is hating
Donald Trump they tried to do it in uh
Virginia with Terry McAuliffe all of the
ads and Terry McAuliffe just kept
repeating Glenn young and is Trump
and that's like all he had it was just I
remember um someone put together a
compilation video it was just Trump
Trump trump it's all cherry McAuliffe
would say so yeah I think uh that that
does hurt overall
um not in all places the Republicans in
the way that it falls with the midterms
after uh taking the house and taking the
Senate it's statistically improbable
that they're going to keep the house
it's just the way hysteria showed it I
want to read this email that I got from
Nancy Pelosi because I was added to a
mailing list oh boy oh I emailed you yes
Nancy Pelosi emailed me and she titled
the email honestly oh
I told you my September 30th deadline
was the biggest of the year I told you
we failed to meet our goal for the first
time ever so today I'm asking you one
final time will you please chip in 15
before midnight to help me finally meet
my goal so that we have the resources to
close out strong and expand our historic
majorities I thought she had a so much
confidence in that this was going to be
a land-sized victory they were going to
gain seats I'll be honest oh we have two
options
boy one either we let the Republicans
win capitalized the fundraising battle
flood capitalized our vulnerable
Democrats with expensive attacks and
Barge their way back in the power or or
we step up we regain the fundraising
Edge and stop Republicans momentum in
its tracks isn't the Democratic party
funding a bunch of the Trump candidates
in some states yes they are because they
it's they're doing what Hillary Clinton
did that's fine
called Trump the Pied Piper it was the
Pied Piper candidate we're going to
amplify him and you know it's it's we're
going to take him out so they're they're
using the same strategy because they
don't learn so uh they're they're
amplifying they're like yeah you know
what this works so well for Hillary
let's do it in all the states so they're
amplifying the Trump candidates and you
know because they're going to be easier
to beat I mean look the the 538 polling
average the real clear politics polling
average both have both predict the
Republicans to gain seats right
according to the most recent ones and
um I think Republicans typically
underperform on the polls so I think uh
it looks pretty great Carrie we're going
to have Carrie Lake in Arizona yeah
I love her she's up by like what two
points overall in the polls so I like to
see the states getting stronger let's
just do this Nancy
let's pull up Nancy Pelosi's
favorability rating from Civics with 203
175 responses
57 unfavorable okay I wanna I wanna ask
you guys about Joe Biden right now
this is the the all all people pulled
right if I select only by democrats do
you think she'll have a favorable or
unfavorable writing among Democrats
unfavorable I think
unfavorable nobody loves me unfavorable
but not in her District okay well I
can't search by that it's either
favorable or not unfavorable all right
and she's
75. why
they like her all right all right I
think it's that bikini photo oh God hold
on hold on Republican party that one's
this nice no-brainer right yeah it's
gonna be like 90
99. hey look at that there's three
percent of the robot
those are the the list Chinese no those
are the people who saw the bikini
picture yeah there you go yeah all right
here's the big here's the important one
though independent voters favorable or
unfavorable
unfavorable unfavorable unfavorable for
sure
wow oh my God am I having a stroke yeah
I mean but this this reminds me of the
recent National poll by the uh what it
was either the Washington Post or the
New York Times and whoever they
partnered with uh asking about
desantis's Bill with um Banning
sexualized curriculum they didn't
explicitly refer to his bill but they
said do you support or oppose having
sexualized curriculum in elementary
school and it was overwhelmingly opposed
overall like 70 to 80 percent among all
voters Nationwide and then among
Republicans it was like 96 opposed to
the that type of curriculum in
elementary schools Independence it was
like 80 90 opposed but Democrats it was
like even wow and it's like it's only
because they know that their party
supported this curriculum in the
classroom so they're just like kind of
hitching themselves too all right to
whatever the party now because because
the question Pelosi uh brings up is will
they win I give you the next poll from
Civics Democratic party favorable rating
registered voters
431 735 responses since 2015.
among Democratic party members do you
think they will have the Democrat they
will view the Democratic party favorably
yeah of course they will of course they
will right
and they do 80 favorable uh they really
like Pelosi though Republicans obviously
don't like it with 96 unfavorable but
the big question is independent voters
what do you guys like this is
a good significance look at the
independency I think 64 unfavorable so
this is the point coming into the
midterms with the Democratic party and
Pelosi the leadership being despised
this much I gotta say it doesn't look
good for them and this idea they're
going to retain it doesn't seem to add
up in the polls however I'm gonna go
back and I'm gonna pull up the uh
Republican party let me see if I can get
the Republican plan here because the
Republican party is always the funniest
one to me
everybody hates Mitch McConnell that's
hilarious
uh let's see where's a Republican party
favorable rating all right so the
Republicans 59 unfavorable among
Democrats kind of obvious right yeah
yeah everybody Democrats just 95 yeah
among independent voters what do you
guys I think it's gonna be even you
think it's gonna be even what do you
guys think slightly over slightly
slightly more favorable I think it's
slightly 61 unfavorable Independence
despise the Republicans here's the best
part among those who are Republicans how
did they view the Republican party
people hate it oh God
no no no 73 is good not as good as the
Democrats yeah not as good as Democrats
in favor of themselves but I do find it
funny that even among the Republican
party they generally like I remember
seeing this when it was like this is you
know back in 2017
32 percent unfavorable like Republicans
really just did not like the Republican
party and even now but I think the
funniest things when you go to like like
Mitch McConnell well you guys get the
point yep it's it's fairly obvious the
big question is where independent's
gonna go if they they hate the
Republicans a little bit less than the
Democrats
I mean I think they go with at least
like I'm I'm mostly buried in the
education stuff The Independents are
going with the Republicans and then if
you just look at what people prefer as
far as what's important to them yes I
think The Independents are going with
the Democrats on the abortion issue but
that's not a top issue the top issue is
economy and the jobs and The
Independents go with the Republicans on
economy and the jobs and look inflation
is horrible right now uh uh just overall
economic outputs not doing really well
which does it help Biden and I think
it's going to help the Republicans there
are two types of Independents that I
know from living in Massachusetts one is
Bernie Sanders who's an independent and
another is the people who are
they don't want to say that they're
Democrats
so they're Independents because they
don't like you know the Socialist aspect
or whatever and they see how that party
is going
um I guess there's three because then
there are the people who don't want to
say that they're Republicans you know
because they don't want the the stigma
attached to it you know um so yeah those
are those are kind of the three main I
mean most voters are Independents right
um or at least the plurality of them
um yeah so it's you know you see the way
The Independents are leaning then you're
like okay I can kind of gauge it you
know from there by who
how they kind of lean within their
independent I like the Mitch McConnell
poll because uh among Republicans 61
unfavorable yeah nobody likes him 17
favorable it's crazy because even Nancy
Pelosi has support from the Democratic
party I wonder what I wonder what 18 to
34 year old Republicans think yeah what
happened what was this the switch
um election time yeah election time yeah
did McConnell come out against Trump or
something at that time is there any
demographic that likes Mitch McConnell
how about the old people
old Republicans don't even like him okay
what about all Republican men no no wow
I mean non-college graduated old no no
all right nobody likes Mitch McConnell
that's it I wonder what the what his
favorability was when the whole cocaine
Mitch drama dropped like the like the 18
to 24 year olds oh yeah look at this
it's cooler now among the men Mitch
McConnell 80 unfavorable among the 83.
I'm like across the board everybody is
like among white people 78 unfavorable
black 93 Hispanic Latino 88 other 85
there's not a single demographic that
holds Mitch McConnell favorably and he
keeps winning I think people just like
yep let's just vote for Mitch and all
incumbents have a huge Advantage yeah
and Kentucky is not really going to vote
for Democrats and he's always going to
win his his uh primary yeah at least it
shows you that the Republican party
isn't so much a cult as the Democrats
are less tribal yeah these people are
like no I don't like the leadership they
suck and the Democrats are like over
Pelosi yeah well they they stick
together they don't they don't divert at
all they're I mean and it's like if
there's even one thing that that they
draw separately on like take abortion
for instance you know like there was a
point where there was even Republicans
were sensitive to the fact that there
could be a 16 year old pregnant girl and
you know like we get that that's that's
terrible you know like she made mistakes
and whatever like there was a point
where that was a thing but then the
Democrats are like nope we're gonna
abort 40 week babies you know we're
gonna work after yeah the baby's born
yeah I mean they just took it and ran
and now it's to a point where it's like
there is no no no level ground at all
like you can't you can't be a Democrat
and say yeah well I I kind of you know
would oppose abortion in the first
trimester because it's like nope you're
you're far right fascist that actually
happened on the show Sheamus is sitting
over here pro-life Catholic the
conservative Matt Bender's over here
Progressive pro-abortion I'm the
traditional you know Pro liberal
pro-choice like after the you know after
visibility again and then he's arguing
with me like I'm the pro-life guy and
I'm like dude I'm the pro-choice guy I'm
trying to help you out here yeah it's
like you're trying to make this you know
palatable again because it's not and
people don't want that and I mean it's
not even that people don't want that
it's statistically something like 80
percent of people support abortion in
the first trimester after into the
second trimester that number plummets to
27 will will support abortion and the
second trimester and third trimester is
like eight percent yeah but that's what
they're running on but have you
considered uh and uh you know Obama gets
this that there's too many kids gotta
blow them up yeah we gotta yeah there's
just too many I think today is also the
anniversary of Obama bombing uh a
charity organization oh the The Doctors
Without Borders Hospital yes oh I
remember when he did that today's
anniversary of that yeah
why won't Obama stop killing children I
was like easy answer too many of them
yeah you know no the Democrats don't
have enough children
well the Democrats certainly look from
the leadership to the the Grassroots
they just think there's too many kids
there's too many policies literally
point to population control you look at
every policy that they push that they
promote every one of them just come out
and say it yeah and then the left are
like oh I'm not going to have any kids
because of the climate it's like no you
want to extend your childhood that's why
you're not gonna have any kids you don't
care about the climate it's also a
responsibility
that's a weird thing too because I don't
understand that idea of like
you know you know what I noticed
there's
there's a lot of bands that I like I'll
just I'll keep it vague there's a lot of
art that I like and there are people
that are like 50 years old still working
and then I'm like why is it that it's
it's considered weird you know like a
band puts out you know some uh some new
music and they're like in their 50s and
their 60s and people are like wow
they're still making music and it's
because back in the day they weren't
still producing they were doing
consulting stuff they're making doing
some stuff but they had a family and
they were raising their family and they
were moving out their lives today
everybody's working and I was like why
is it that these people and then I
looked I'm like none of these people
have kids so like their whole lives are
just product and not family and so it's
a really interesting phenomenon to see
I don't know if like for these
Millennials uh and and just this current
generation of whatever
I don't understand you know I don't
think it's it's prolonging childhood
necessarily I I think it's it's it's
maybe just programming thanks for
checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there